here in this sleepy hills of Saxony
high-tech textile production facilities
are springing up the spec on company is
taking advantage of the region's history
as a textile manufacturing stronghold
this factory used to employ two and a
half thousand people now 25 employees
suit together high performance fabrics
used in parachutes and uniforms their
clients are from the military and
aerospace sectors the company says it's
able to compete against asian
manufacturers skeet helped make
indicates mainly a question of quality
that's why we've stayed in Germany we
highly specialized and we can only
guarantee this level of quality at this
location if we moved abroad we could
save money but we'd have quality control
problems quality it's really quiet
across the border in the Czech Republic
University researchers and their
students are developing new textiles
they're patenting their inventions and
licensing them to companies like spec on
these fabrics have special requirements
some must be fireproof or offer
extremely high resistance to tearing or
bare heavy loads here a researcher is
using a heat-sensitive camera to figure
out what combination of fabrics works
best for sporting or military clothing
we try to measure comfort of textile
material new branch this opening it is a
special textile for car index industry
mainly for car seats when we want to
improve comfort of car seats some
students have also received patents for
their work these doctoral candidates are
studying how body heat interacts with
textiles this item for instance might
end up being a fashion accessory the
t-shirt changes color and reaction to
changes in temperature there are also
clothing materials made for the blind
blind people
read on their dress or shirts about care
how to care how to iron how to wash or
about the size information about the
colors and everything what they need
back in Saxony spec on is still
concentrating on high-performance
materials for the army business is
growing but they work slowly inspecting
each seam before delivery